[Music]
more information has now come out about
the secret surface prostitution scandal
in Colombia have you been following this
story secret service it what does that
noise mean does that mean yes we've been
following it no we haven't been
following it or we're drowning in gravy
[Music]
Secret Service agents in in Colombia I
guess yeah charged with trying to
solicit prostitutes spending time with
prostitutes one of these Secret Service
agents is in trouble now for bragging to
the prostitutes that they were there to
protect President Obama he was bragging
yeah so the agents first mistake was
thinking you have to brag to a
prostitute let's see thinking I don't
know they're like you got the money you
don't have the money right let me tell
you more in my experience they don't
care all right
and in my experience you can't brag
while you're crying
you doesn't work it's clear now while
your kids have those signs
President Obama has ordered an
investigation into the Secret Service
sex scandal yeah and before Obama had
even finished issuing the order Bill
Clinton said I am on it
[Applause]
he has his bag tied right I even have a
superhero outfit I put on I'm gonna talk
to everybody I get to the bottom of this
well now that he's the Republican
nominee Mitt Romney trying very hard to
connect with voters Thanks they say it
might be his problem connecting with
real people so Mitt Romney is now saying
he said he isn't too rich to relate to
average Americans that's what he said
yeah he said just cuz I own six houses
doesn't mean I can't relate to someone
who only owns three strong an Romney
meanwhile is now defending her husband
for once strapping the family dog to the
roof of their station wagon on a family
trip saying the dog loved it yeah
unfortunately the dog could not be
reached for comment because he ran away
to stay with Michael Vick
with dog also had luggage just like
Clinton is yogge was back to tough times
for Newt Gingrich this is crazy during a
campaign event at the st. Louis Zoo Newt
Gingrich was bitten by a penguin yeah
yeah partly it was feeding time in
Newton the penguin were fighting over
pieces of squid you like the premise
more than the punchline there you can't
beat Newt was bitten by a penguin my
mistake was I thought I needed a joke
after that I had them just at the truth
yeah I know you're like we're good we're
all right yesterday Washington DC
celebrated Emancipation Day the
anniversary of President Lincoln freeing
the slaves yeah to patient oh yeah
Emancipation Day or as the tea party
calls it the day government intruded on
small business owners
I don't know this a record number of
Americans now I now owe so much in back
taxes that they are renouncing their US
citizenship yeah
these Americans have all been offered
safe haven in the country of Nicolas
Cage's Stan nice country yeah the speed
limit is 150 yeah
mandatory yeah in London this is in
London there's a new service that
delivers the morning-after pill to your
home by bicycle messenger yeah and to
make sure you don't regret your decision
the pills will be delivered by kids who
are obnoxious jerks
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]